the number of people that are arriving
at our border
is at an extraordinary height there's no
question about that but that is not
unique to the southern border of the
United States there is a tremendous
amount of movement throughout the
hemisphere and in fact throughout the
world
HS secretary Alejandra mayork is
attempting to defend the growing border
crisis despite CBP tracking more than
one million encounters at the Southwest
border alone this year is that
explanation good enough former DHS
Deputy assistant secretary John Fahey
joins us now to react Jonathan great to
see you this morning let's sort of fact
check that if we might just to start he
says Across the Western Hemisphere we
see border crossings all over I I would
guess by the way it's less about border
crossings and more about where they're
attempting to stop crossing the border
where these illegal immigrants are
attempting to stay that might
distinguish the southern Board of the
United States from say the southern
border of Mexico which is a way station
yeah every time you listen to them it's
really breathtaking because it's either
complete lies or utter nonsense and
that's a combination of both the reason
we're having this issue is because of
their policies there's no other reason
because they have told anyone in the
world if they get to our country They
will receive every benefit American
citizens get plus they get a free cell
phone when they get here just as a
little bonus point so every time I
listen to them it really is ridiculous
and he knows better and if he doesn't
know better he has to be the most
incompetent person to ever have any job
but he knows exactly what's going on
yeah strikes me if a Venezuelan is
trying to get to America and Crosses all
the Central American borders and the
Mexican border it's not a western
hemisphere border crisis it's an
American crisis they're all trying to
get to America by the way he won't say
that Jonathan he won't call it a crisis
watch this
do you view what's happening right now
in the border is a crisis I view it as a
significant challenge why won't you say
the word crisis you know what because I
have tremendous faith in the people of
the Department of Homeland Security and
a crisis speaks to me uh of a withdrawal
uh from our mission
well that's fascinating so let's reverse
that Jonathan do they have does that
border patrol agency do those agents
have faith in DHS do they have faith in
mayorkas and is there not a withdrawal
on behalf of mayorkas in in with in in
fulfilling that mission
yeah exactly they have no faith in him
and that little game of acting like he's
supporting the agents remember what he
did to the agents a year ago accused of
whipping the migrants it's utter
nonsense whether they call it a crisis
who cares what you call it we have an
open border that's causing harm to
Americans we have over a hundred
thousand overdose deaths a year and they
simply don't care and it's not a
challenge because they want it to happen
this is a victory for this
Administration make no mistake about
this they campaign on this and they want
this to happen and they will die on this
hill they are fighting for this every
single day to keep this border open let
me move to this with you Jonathan this
morning
um let me put this in context for well
um a shrine to Santa Muerte which is
it's it's big within the Mexican drug
cartel Community the saint of death was
found at a Stash House in Texas now
here's the context 261 stash houses have
been discovered holding a total of three
thousand migrants inside and then you
find doubt about this this Shrine to
Santa Muerte in Texas what significance
does that hold for you
well it does show the human trafficking
and the illegal immigration is
intertwined with the drug trafficking
and again this administration's policies
of open borders have increased both to
to record levels but I do think these
drug traffickers are somewhat misplaced
here because really if they're being
honest they should have a shrine to
secretary mayorkas in there because he's
the real reason they're able to enjoy so
much success and so much riches and
really didn't know that they could do
what they want to do with absolute
impunity I do think it's a mark of uh in
continued cultural influence and
presence not just on the southern side
of that border but on the Northern side
of that border this is in Texas Jonathan
Faye great to talk to you this morning
thank you I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis